[Musique]
après douze années au pouvoir le premier
ministre d'israël benyamin nétanyahou a
réussi à unir contre lui des partis
politiques ou idéologiques qui semblent
irréconciliables
cette alliance entre toutes les
tendances politiques le facteur le
ciment principale qui la constituent
c'est effectivement l'opposition à
natanya où que ce soit sur le plan
idéologique et politique
et puis n'oubliez pas quand même le fait
que le même natanyahou premier ministre
d'israël comparer trois fois par semaine
à son procès pour charges de corruption
au bout de deux mois de tractations une
majorité fragile et disparate s'est
dessiné autour de huit partis politiques
dont 3 d'extrême droite et un parti se
déclarant de la mouvance des frères
musulmans limite togo faut un ego chez
swiss de pao sting et pour réussir ce
pari le centriste yaïr lapid chargé de
former un gouvernement à courtiser
naftali bennet chef d'une petite
formation de droite en lui offrant de
devenir premier ministre jusqu'en 2023
même si son parti ne dispose que de 6
sièges à la knesset mais naftali bennett
et surtout un allié de la première heure
de benyamin nétanyahou est un partisan
de la colonisation qui rêvent d'annexer
une grande partie de la cisjordanie
occupée sur l'annexion par exemple il ne
bougera pas pour une raison très simple
parce que le locataire de la maison
blanche pour quatre ans et by dell et
joba eden n'autorisera pas le
gouvernement israélien à aller de
l'avant avec ce projet d'adduction autre
alliance improbable celle avec le parti
islamiste rab une première depuis que
les partis arabes avaient soutenu issac
rabin dans les années 90 une majorité
d'israéliens de savoir qu à la même
table
il y aura des arabes des juifs des
religieux des laïcs des ongs hausse des
ventes de droite
eh bien ça peut peut-être calmer le jeu
parce que nous sortons vraiment très
divisée vous avez lu
mais rien n'est encore gagné le vote
décisif pour cette coalition devrait se
tenir mercredi prochain à la knesset
dont la présidence est assurée par le
likoud le parti de benyamin nétanyahou
d'ailleurs ce dernier a déjà prévenu
qu'il tentera de faire éclater la
coalition
s'il ne parvient pas fait repousser le
vote à une date ultérieure ici s
mitraillette radio canada montréal